[Music]
let's be honest some kids toys are
pretty weird you'd never expect kids to
play with something as strange as this
but yet here we are stay tuned to hear
about one of the grossest toy trends
that will take over toy stores in 2018
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up and subscribe to the things now let's
check out ten weird toys kids will
actually love do you want to be a DIY
expert check out our friends at crafty
hackers they have the best hacks crafts
and everything DIY watch their videos
for the best household tricks DIY decor
and fun recipes if you love making
crafts with your friends or just trying
new things they have everything you're
looking for be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any awesome hacks and
craft slime let's start with one of the
latest trends that took over the entire
Internet in 2016 they call it the slime
economy and it became so popular kids
are actually making it and selling it
themselves but this weird toy made of
blue water and borax is also used as a
tool to relax and de-stress it might
seem weird and totally unappealing to
someone that doesn't particularly enjoy
slimy and sticky stuff but we're telling
you you'll be hooked slime is
stretchable it's palpable and it can
come with thousands of different types
of colors this phenomenon is extremely
popular with kid instagramers however
it's no stranger to YouTube influencers
and practically anyone that's keeping up
with the latest trends and you can blame
the towel the creators of the original
slime and even back but it was crowned
as the grossest toy ever of course that
would make it perfect for kids once
people realize how easy it is to
actually make this strange putty if they
started experimenting with different
types and colors you can make cloud
slime butter slime classic slime and
even phloem Sime which comes with
styrofoam beads the options are endless
and we promise that every kid will
actually fall in love with it
feisty pets when you see a plush toy you
automatically expect it to be soft and
cute but that's not the case with feisty
pets well they are soft and cute
but only until you squeeze them then
they turn into this completely weird toy
that's actually pretty funny we can
imagine a couple of kids out there that
would have a real fun with this toy and
scare their family members they come
with funny names
- there's Glinda glitter poop Sammie
sucker punch and plenty of other choices
out there Gooden is a perfect unicorn
and Sammy's the best dog ever there are
also the most perfect collectibles ever
imagine giving this to someone and not
telling them that they totally change
their face when you squeeze them it's
the most amazing prank ever seriously
this is the type of toy we'd definitely
play with and we have a feeling we're
not the only ones sure it's weird but we
all know kids love weird stuff there's
no wonder they call these pricey pets
just check out the face they make you
probably wouldn't want to mess with them
would you but it would be fun to mess
with other people with these amazing
toys just don't squeeze them too hard
when you cuddle them at night or they
might go from nice to totally feisty
Furby let's be honest
BRR bees are weird toys you actually end
up loving after a while sure they might
be annoying they might never turn off
and they might even wake you up at night
but hey it's a haul and good fun BRR
bees were invented in 1998 and they were
one of the first robotic toys that can
be trained and interacts with you well
sort of train Furbys just kind of do
their own thing but they do allow you to
feed them the very first fir bees were
around until 2007 and then brought back
several times before the ultimate
comeback in 2016 just look at these
adorable creatures they dance around
they're friendly and they'll even
uncontrollably giggle when you tried it
to go them their voice might be weird
but trust us you'll end up totally
loving this furry toy and since the new
fur bees also connect to various apps
and allow you to feed and play with them
through the app they're totally in sync
with modern technology so once you get
past the part that they just looked
completely weird you're guaranteed to
fall in love with these furry funny
creatures what do you think is it a yay
or a nay for Furbies creepy crawlers
just the name itself makes this toy
weird but it's not what you think it is
creepy crawlers is a classic toy from
the 70s that made a comeback in the 90s
after popular demand this strange toy
set is made of an
and several molds that look like bugs
you then take that substance called
classy goop from that mold pop it in the
oven and you'd get a so-called creepy
crawler if done correctly these toy bugs
would be slightly sticky which would
allow you to throw them against the
window and then watch the bug make its
way down almost as if it's alive you
could also get several mould sets
including fighting-men dragon's flowers
and even peanuts characters since kids
love to make new exciting things as
demonstrated by the slime trend we have
a feeling that many would actually love
the creepy crawler sets it's almost like
you're 3d printing your toys which is
incredibly cool sure these are bugs but
think about all the possibilities we
know there's at least one kid out there
that could turn their creepy crawlers
into a pretty successful business and
probably have a lot of Instagram
followers because of these weird toys
let's make it happen
glowworms you thought fur bees were
weird bees were an actual craze back in
the day yep
these are plushy worms that kind of look
like humans in a nightgown they even
come with an adorable nightcap and the
best part their faces glow in the dark
and play lullabies when you squeeze them
sure a worm wasn't exactly an
appropriate choice for a toy but hey in
today's world kids absolutely love
creepy weird stuff like this
glow worms became popular in the u.s. in
1982 they were known as the cuddliest
nightlight ever and we have a feeling
they'd still be called that today isn't
it pretty cool it's a snuggly toy a
nightlight and an actual plush firm at
the same time these worms became so
popular the company behind them later
introduced a glowworm crib light and
even a worm themed board game we're not
sure what's weirder a plush firm toy
that glows in the dark or a warm light
crib light you could also get the
miniature versions of these strange
worms and turn them into collectibles
the options were unless well that is if
you like toy worms seriously what's with
kids and their love for strange toy
worms and bugs we bet there are still
kids that would love to snuggle up with
this light-up worm today puppy surprise
kids once loved this toy so why wouldn't
they love it now too sure it'll probably
be a bit outdated but we're sure there's
an app that could fix that how many of
you remember puppy surprise it's a toy
that taught kids all about how puppies
born who else order this toy consisted
of a big dog which had tons of different
colors as well as a Velcro when you
opened it up you'd find actual plush
puppies inside and that's not the actual
surprise sure seen puppies is exciting
but this toy was all about how many
puppies you actually got the best part
about this toy was that you were able to
get three four or five baby puppies the
puppies also came with different outfits
and differently colored hair of course
kids that only got three puppies
complained so the toy companies started
selling the puppies separately trust us
you didn't want to be the kid that got
only three puppies in the litter but the
point is no matter how weird this toy is
we know there are kids that would
actually be totally fascinated by
finding a little extra toy inside not to
mention that the mommy dogs were super
funky Cabbage Patch Kids Cabbage Patch
Kids might be a weird toy we used to
love in the 90s but did you know that
they haven't even bigger history this
popular toy actually had a song to go
along that explained the origin behind
the Cabbage Patch Kids and according to
this song the Cabbage Patch Kids are
children that were born without parents
they're obviously born at a Cabbage
Patch but they need to get adopted soon
because otherwise they'll be kidnapped
by a business owner that lives nearby
and he wants to turn the Cabbage Patch
kids into slaves
we're not kidding you that's the actual
backstory but aside from that these
cuddly dolls were extremely popular in
the 90s by 1990 people have adopted over
60 million of these strange dolls they
have definitely been the most loved
dolls ever and we have a feeling they'd
still be popular now even though they
might have a slightly weird origin
behind them what's best about them is
you can also collect them and see just
how many Cabbage Patch Kids you can
officially adopt aka purchase it's an
interesting concept that would
definitely be just as entertaining today
but we bet modern technology can make
these kiddos look even better
Pachi Pachi clappy okay this one is just
absolutely hilarious we have a feeling
any parent will regret buy in this
strange toy for their kid when they
realize just how annoying it actually is
but hey that's what it's all about
right it might have a funny name but
Pachi Pachi clappy is one of the most
glorious toys ever it's known as Japan's
favorite
official clapping device that's right
you can now have a toy do the clapping
for you the toy is very simple and comes
with an adorable but slightly weird face
two hands and a trigger button just
press the button and this strange toy
will clap until you tell it to stop you
can even control how many claps you want
it to do we have a feeling there are a
couple of sarcastic kids out there that
will definitely know how to give this
toy the sense of humor it deserves to
have what's even better is that this
toys mouth will open only when you press
the trigger button a perfect toy for
someone that does a lot of bopping or
just someone who can't be bothered
seriously this one is one of our
favorites and only two other toys can
top it
Tamagotchi a virtual animal sure it
might sound weird but also yes please
Tamagotchi came back and if you haven't
tried it yet you absolutely have to this
digital pet phenomenon dates back to
1996 where the first toy sold more than
40 million units worldwide
it's really strange to be able to have a
pet on a keychain but yet here we are
to make the time I got you survived you
need to feed it play with it clean up
after it and in general take care of it
and if you don't you won't be able to
get a new one you only get one so it's
important to keep it alive and well it
might be a lot of responsibility for a
kid but we bet there still are kids out
there that would love to have a virtual
pet like this one and not just kids
we're sure that there are plenty of
adults that would want to play with
Tamagotchis again of course you can now
get a new Tamagotchi which is still
fairly the same except a little bit
smaller all you need to do is pull the
tap bring it to life and keep it alive
has sounds simple right
poop since the poop emoji became so
popular in 2016 and 2017
Gizmodo was crowned 2018 as the gear of
poop kits toys as weird as it might
sound we're pretty sure there are toys
out there kids with love even if it
means they'll be playing with fake poop
seriously nothing surprises us anymore
when it comes to kids from slimy stuff
and bugs to straight-up poop but it
seems that the toy makers are catching
on this strange trend because plenty of
people created some really impressive
toys and pay a tribute to your number
two activity in the bathrooms sounds
pretty gross right our favorite strange
toy in the proof category is deaf
don't step in it toy by Hasbro this game
is all about being careful because if
you're not you'll stuff in fake poo you
get to put on a blindfold have your
teammates spend the spinner and whatever
number you get on the spinner that's how
many steps you need to take on the don't
step in the mats of course there's a lot
of fake poop on it that you need to
avoid be barefoot for extra gross points
sure it might be weird but we have a
feeling a lot of kids will actually love
this one and that's all for our video
don't forget to subscribe to the things
and tell us how you felt about this
video thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]